it sounds like your mom is still quite
involved I read a story somewhere about
that you were giving birth and your
mother was very she is involved when
she's there she's involved and then she
goes
um oh she was like in my vagina I mean
it was like you couldn't
get more inside of a birthing vagina
than my mother and and she had these
like reading glasses on that had lights
on
[Applause]
what a privilege though
follow the light
out of the kid but but the thing is is
that having mommy there as funny as it
is was really really special yeah yeah
so she is involved and do you know the
story I'm talking about where like you
do not win any awards for being a good
daughter there are many stories where I
don't wear I was not a great dude I
would I I'm forever in my mum's debt
because I was such a brat and I feel
really bad about it tell us a story
about when you were on your computer and
she wanted your help oh yes she yes okay
so I um I was on MSN uh obviously the
most important thing at the time
and uh we moved out like you know out in
the sticks and often snakes would get
into the house and
um you know it wasn't a big deal but you
just have to like chase them around and
get it out and it's kind of time
consuming and annoying and so my mom
yelled out and she was like can you come
help me this this snake's really big
like I can't get it on my own can you
come help me and I was like
so busy mum no I can't like just being a
brat because I was on a mission and she
was like oh I just like hey are you she
plays and I was like be gone and um and
then she was she was gone for like 10
minutes and I was like
oh she's been going for ages and then I
I like got up from the computer I could
hear like this
and I was like oh God what's happening
and I see mum she's like made halfway
down the stairs and the snake she tried
to like pick this big python up with her
but with a broom and a stick but it had
wound its way up around her arm and was
going around her neck
Australia but I would never be able to
no I know I'm painting a bad picture
it's really not bad but um
poisonous state but they do they do they
do strangle you oh yeah
you just got to give it something else
to climb once you get a stick or
something it starts weaving its way
around that and then you can transfer
its weight and good to know get it off
just you grab it behind its head you
grab it behind it
you just don't want it to bite you
mother okay
fine I've got
I tried not to be such a brat when Mom
asked for help in future I I kind of did
it a lesson a lesson were you allowed
kind of treats to the White House could
you have junk food and yeah yeah yeah
like they're on the weekends
yeah I mean on the weekends I mean it
was pretty strict during the week and
then more relaxed on the weekend and
could you have people over could friends
come over and stuff yeah oh yeah oh I
mean the place was filled with her
friends yeah absolutely and and you know
it's true that you know the White House
does like to prepare all the food
um and the kids were not always
enthusiastic about the food
they were being served so they were
always trying to call for pizzas
and you can't order a pizza to the White
House I'll just tell you that right now
and we did sometimes there were
exceptions yeah sometimes you could go
out maybe and one of the kids could go
out maybe and meet the and pick it up
yeah yeah but the first time you would
have thought that you know War had been
declared there's a pizza truck
it says hey pizza was ordered what do we
do with it yeah it we had lots of
challenges like that
sounds like a crank call
from the pizza restaurants you want some
pizzas at the White House yes thank you
very much we're very busy
the last I think was the last time we
were here uh Kelly brought her daughter
she was young yeah
look at those cheeks look at her head
and the happiest baby I have ever
encountered I mean yeah and now
miserable
and she's super happy and then all of a
sudden just like super not yeah it's
really fun but he's not
but she likes you didn't mean the word
friendly yeah
it's like you know take the wine in a
bathroom and cry it out with God
like I don't want to kill her
I still love you she's super great
though sometimes she's like this little
unicorn sometimes she's very magical
very um infectious in a good way
[Applause]
is it a real bear
but it's not the song loves us off that
she likes well she does but she can't
say her ABS yet so it sounds like her
mother's an alcoholic because she says
love so soft
we have a very Drunken Love at our
household she just can't say her F so
it's kind of fun to hear her sing all
the songs yeah your daughter has she
seen your stuff no okay well I haven't
had anything child friendly yeah well
that's how I feel that's about it for
the first one yeah yeah come on from
here
but you must see your picture on TV and
stuff she has discovered that you can
have my face as a person on Netflix or
for like your avatar oh yeah yeah that's
amazing
I didn't know that she'd done this and I
turned on Netflix like she'd gone to bed
with my face she called it nincompoop
like
I don't think you want anyone an income
but she spelled it perfectly and it's
just my face
are you still watching this nincompoop
this is what you like to watch what do
you recommend you watch I can't go
anywhere near it but I also can't delete
it because I'm quite proud of how she
managed to find it and do that yeah in
some scenes you are pregnant well yes we
did some additional photography and I
was pregnant and it was kind of still
early so I wasn't really telling anyone
and so Tom was confused as to why I
wasn't engaging in all the stunts
because I was kind of game for it when
we did the original shoot and eventually
I went because I'm growing a human
and he was so cute about it and then
protected me was helping me downstairs
like it was almost overboard you know
which is like Tom Tom I'm fine I can do
stairs
at human and little human popped out
we've got a picture of Hazel oh
yeah as a mother that must be so nice to
have 600 people go
[Applause]
it is very nice yeah because I do that
but yeah she is really cute she's so
cute was it the nurse that was very
complimentary yeah she was funny we were
in the recovery room afterwards and we
had this amazing nurse who came in and
she looked at me so she goes
Sam your baby is so cute and I went I
went oh really she went she is gorgeous
and I went Mabel I think you say that to
all the mothers and she went no I don't
to say he said when I know a baby ugly I
say you had a baby
growing up was it a nice thing that your
mom was Jennifer Saunders or was it kind
of an embarrassing thing I mean I I
don't mean the actual woman I mean the
idea yeah well I think I sort of assumed
that everyone's mum and dad was on telly
I was like so what show is your dad on
but I did come home one day and ask her
if she was Jennifer Saunders yeah
because I didn't understand what I
didn't know yeah
someone at school had said yeah oh your
mum's Jennifer Saunders I was like all
right
and but of course not just moment dad in
Edmonton yes yes so did they give you
advice going into comedy and things
um I mean yeah I'm sure I think probably
one really good bit of advice my dad
gave me when a boy at my school had got
told off for doing a fart in class like
a really loud one um and so I came home
and I told my dad and he was like BT and
he got really serious he's like BT
don't you ever let anyone tell you that
farting isn't funny
careers have been made it built this
house
your mom she sounds formidable uh so I
love this story so you you graduated
from dance school you go home to
Malaysia and what has your mother done
ah so as I got home for the holidays and
I was planning to go back to England
then she suddenly looped into this whole
thing about oh you know you should go on
stage more and you should do this
because now you're 21 and when you're
not 21 anymore the things you can do and
I'm thinking what on Earth is she on
about the next thing I knew was my
brother she looped my brother into doing
he said yeah yeah you should try it out
I'm like what are you guys she had
entered me for Miss Malaysia
find the form so technically I'm not
legit but
but you think oh terrible things to do
you won
[Applause]
oh my God
I did it to shut her off
because she wouldn't stop about it so I
said we had a deal if I do this you are
never going to do something like this
again yeah and what age were you when
she insisted on coming on a date with
you oh
now you have to remember they're very
very moms are very protective right for
all the right reasons so oh she always
went on a date oh always always until I
went to England to study I don't know
why she even let me go to England so
when we go on dates she literally will
sit I'll be here the guy was here and
you know we're 17 or whatever so one
time I was sitting like this and I
suddenly realized why are there two
hands on my leg so it was his hand on my
mouth
wow you know like he was holding the
hand he thought was mine and then I
looked at him like excuse me guys
obviously your mother loves you because
you're her daughter but she is actually
a sort of a fan as well you know it's
not he's not quite that it's um no she
is oh goodness right so my uh uh one day
my mum came to set on the Star Wars set
uh and I was getting this thing called
cyberskand which is where you stand in
this kind of loads of cameras and they'd
kind of take your form and put you into
a computer and make a toy or a some sort
of merchandise or your face on a cushion
um and so I do often do this and I come
back and mum's like I've made a great
friend and I'm like brilliant it's
lovely excellent and uh she's likes the
merchandise you know director of all of
Star Wars or something I'm like what
else are you very impressive
um and then before I know it what comes
in the post
um is loads of cushions
my face on it
it's not enough so yeah
I was kind of Blown Away how much
merchandise there is yes
it's just the beginning it was like the
pre-merchandise not even the real stuff
is out yet and my mum has all of it and
it doesn't know about the dog yet so
this is so weird I don't know is this in
your flat or her house right okay so
basically she thought it'd be really
funny if I came home and it was
everywhere in my room okay so this is
this is this is Amelia's actual bedroom
[Music]
oh
foreign